a little bit off the charts yeah when it
comes to the movements higher well how's
this for timing mark we are just one
week shy of the 15-year anniversary when
the Nasdaq first reached five thousand
back on March ninth two thousand and
then the following day said its record
high of 50 48.6 two so this is today's
chart it shows the recovery back to
those levels you have two distinct peaks
the first one on the far left is a
dot-com bubble the sharp move up and
then the precipitous drop down with the
Nasdaq bottoming in October of 2002
closing at eleven fourteen what we saw
was the index doubling in value in the
run-up to the housing bubble but it
didn't even reclaim three thousand
before it was knocked down again by the
subprime crisis the low set in 2009 was
a higher low than the load that we saw
in 2002 and since then it's been a
pretty steady climb up and Jamie if we
can pull that chart back up again you
can see the trajectory of the increase
makes it look a little less extreme than
the last time around Scarlett let's
revisit the first trip to 5,000 it was a
pretty rapid move past 2000 3000 4000
than 5,000 how do you quantify how long
it took to get there the first time
around versus what we're seeing this
cycle well I use a Bloomberg terminal
this is a shameless plug of course I was
able to calculate the number of days it
took for us to get from 4,000 5,000 and
what's notable is that this time around
he took about 15 months to go from 4,000
to 5,000 in 1999 to 2000 roughly 10
weeks so this time around 461 actual
days 313 trading days in 1999 to 2071
actual days 49 trading days that just
gives you a sense of how rushed how much
of a frenzy how frothy it was back then
the scarlet when it comes to
fundamentals what's the big difference
this time around well the big
differences valuations are not as
stretched as a war in the.com frenzy do
you remember the PEG ratio the price to
earnings to growth ratio that people
concoct it as a way to value of earnings
in the Nasdaq we're not really talking
about that anymore so let's go with the
old-school metric of p/e ratios price to
earnings which looks at historical
earnings or maybe estimated earnings one
to two quarters out right now the NASA
currently trades it under 32 times
earnings
that's a far right side of the chart in
march two thousand mark when the nasdaq
set is high the p/e was 175 valuations
then skyrocketed as earnings cratered
and companies went under in the crash
that followed that's when the p/e got to
almost 600 above 500 in december of 2001
so we're a long way off from those
levels we probably won't revisit those
levels again if you look at how big and
influential tech is now versus when it
was in 2000 it's interesting here
because tech makes up a smaller part of
the sp500 now then back that twenty
percent versus thirty-five percent back
then yet it's more influential in
earnings making up nineteen percent of
operating earnings as opposed to
thirteen percent back in two thousand